so part of me with will it's like i get
it you get it yeah i get it but well but
also we have to remember that will's
been taking will's been sitting in his
seat taking it he's taking all of it all
the [ __ ]
finally he's like you know what the
internet cop yeah i'm gonna make i'm
gonna five years
you can't push me it was it's been that
was five years if if my girl was let's
say i was uh married to jada smith and
she goes i'm gonna start red table tell
you oh do we not have enough money
right for what but she she never has
enough attention bubba but i would just
go oh she can't go and usually talk
about our personal life oh yeah what's
wrong with whatever it is she puts it
all out there you talk about missing
tupac and the letters he said what's
wrong with you whatever it does not have
enough money whatever it takes i go oh
i'm out yeah oh i'm out me too oh then
in an interview i think charlemagne had
asked him about the tupac situation so
it's like now he's going to ask and it
was after she had visited
so now he's getting these like interview
questions about tupac
yeah that's the problem she has no
respect but she bit that's how she takes
his power
away can you imagine
let's say your girl dated some f let's
say she dated heath ledger a man who
passed away rest in peace
and and that was years ago way before
you yeah and every time his birthday
comes up she's posting about him posting
letters but what are you doing i'd have
a huge what the [ __ ] are you doing i
don't deal with that where's the respect
i go like this i go where's the respect
i go like this you see you yeah that's
what i do i would always do that i if
you don't like me or you're gonna do
that like i've been i've had that before
with a woman who like dissed me one time
she started we were dating for a little
bit and she was just inappropriately
hanging out with this district i was
like oh okay yeah so i went like this i
go so this is all good
you buy i just went i'll do it every
year yeah dude
relationship my joke would if i'm chris
rock i would have been like all right
well oh you want to hit me on the street
all right i'm gonna [ __ ] your your i'm
gonna [ __ ] jaden i'm gonna go for jada
now you know really show him the [ __ ]
jada i'm gonna [ __ ] the mom that's
what's happening now yeah
just straight up yeah because we know
you guys get down like that
jim carrey went on what was talking
about it was really he had a great take
on it what do you say
he said it was just you stole the people
that the devotion
that it takes to get to that to pull it
off it's their biggest night and you
stole everybody's fire when you walked
up there and slapped him like that yeah
like you didn't have the self-control
and it just came out of [ __ ] nowhere
and it wasn't that bad he just he just
went really hard he just took the spot
he's the only because i love i love will
smith but that was you gotta you at
least you gotta say what you did was
wrong there's not gray area here that
sucked that sucked you just can't have
it also kid i don't know how many kids
are watching no also now that nobody's
watching but kids watching it well now
it's like now that's all that more i
know especially on tick tock and all
that one guy was saying you know so kids
you're making violence okay you really
are right and whether you think that not
everybody's going to do that because
what do we say what do you say use your
words don't use violence and now kids
are like well will smith uses violence
like the the
the
standard that you're setting is not good
use the words until i until i can't take
it anymore and i want to really hit
somebody it's like you know what i'm
saying is like there's no it hit a
smaller man yeah what i think is
happening is it's like the kid in school
his kid in school is getting bullied
bullied bullied will's getting bullied
bullied his wife's [ __ ] all these
other dudes he's getting bleed bloody
blood
and then the kind of nerdy artistic kid
goes oh this is everyone's doing that
let me try it after months goes hey
[ __ ] dummy and then will goes what
and punches that kid yes and so the big
bullies who are really doing it yes and
to be honest it all stems from his wife
brian you ruined away from her dude
right you really think she's trying to
take her take his power 100 to i think
with that talk like
listen and that's fair that you say that
but i'm just like but like i mean i
don't know i don't know i don't know if
i would give her a humiliated your
husband you are humiliating your husband
over and over again you've ruined his
brand and i mean you've ruined this
brand and and everyone calls him a cup
people [ __ ] with willis
he's not yeah but but she's not being
respectful of that i don't respect them
she's not i got a huge problem yeah i
got a problem with it huge problem with
her she's not being respectful at all
and she's doing it why because it
monetizes her monetization it gives her
gives her power yeah and it gets her
view she can't handle the fact that he's
amazing she can't handle the fact that
he's at the top of this game she can't
handle the fact that he won an oscar
you know what happened after he won the
oscar did she give a big hug and a kiss
no they held hands like this watched the
rest of it and they went to afterparties
and danced to get jiggy with it in
[ __ ] miami whatever this song is all
right there you go i [ __ ] with that song
i [ __ ] with all songs
welcome to miami
that song
come on so if will smith is already
laughing will smith himself found that
joke to be fun to him at that moment
right he was laughing so then to look
back and see this girlfriend who i'm
sure we all have
yeah we do yeah it's clear footage of
that here's my thing i think will was
like yeah that's funny and then he
looked and he was like oh i better do
something
[ __ ] little wayne
i i looked for it i could i didn't see
where that was where he looks back at
his wife it's everywhere dude but it's
everywhere brian you know i i did not
see that it's different
bro i saw it and i don't watch a [ __ ]
i saw it on the shitty clip mark
sentence
i'm but did you see him look at her yes
and he's laughing looks over and she
rolls around okay look at him right
there look at him oh [ __ ] and look at
her
ah she's not happy with it jada i love
you g.i jane 2 can't wait to see it all
right
see he's laughing and look at her
yeah so honestly it's lame yeah you have
disagreements with your girlfriend too
right i mean with your girl i have
disagreements sometimes i think certain
things are funny she doesn't i'm not
going to look at her and she'll be like
wait you didn't think it's funny i'm
going to go [ __ ] this guy up now well
look i'm not him i think he was like oh
if i don't do this she's going to [ __ ]
little uzi which is still lame you know
still lame
joke itself is like the most little
[ __ ] thing it's so weak it's so weird
like a great question
yeah
she has a bald head okay almost in a
sense of combination
i don't think he knew that she had that
alopecia also also
cgi chain too are you talking about
where demi moore's a badass and hot as
[ __ ] that's what i'm talking about
that's what i'm talking about she was
hot as [ __ ]
that movie's great
yeah gij and two would be lit as [ __ ]
would jada what come on i don't want to
see her in it but yeah i thought
i'm
let me see what he said violence is in
all of its forms his poisons destructed
my parents academy awards were not
acceptable inexcusable jokes at my
expense are part of the job but a joke
about jada's medical condition was too
much for me to bear and i reacted
emotionally
i'd like to publicly apologize to you
chris i was out of line i was wrong i'm
bearing some actions we're not
indicative of the man i want to be
there's no place for violence in this
world of love and kindness
i also like to apologize to the academy
the producers of the show all the
attendees everyone watching around the
world i would like to apologize to the
williams family and my king and my king
richard family i deeply regret that my
behavior has
stained what was been in an otherwise
gorgeous journey for all of us i'm a
work in progress look i love the guy
i love the guy and i accept his apology
i love will smith yeah i don't care i
don't care enough
again
he [ __ ] up very black point in the day
it's another billionaire
and he just [ __ ] made a mistake
everybody's alright everybody's talking
let's leave them alone